all right plenty of dirty laundry
in houston and uh one one specific pile
that they refuse to deal with is the
desean watson situation now watson had a
tweet earlier today a cryptic tweet
current and former texans players love
that now loyalty is everything don't you
ever forget it all caps ever
um well okay fine but who's he talking
about is there somebody else that he's
upset with were the texans not loyal to
him in some way what did they do that
reflected a lack of loyalty it raises a
lot of questions but then the answer was
supplied by espn which reported that
deshaun watson has met with new coach
david cully and refuses to play
for
the texans
not a surprise we've known that i i
almost feel like
the texans are that kid and i was that
kid five years old i saw the little
metal cap on the pilot light on the
stove and i was fascinated by it and i
was reaching for it and as my finger was
going through the air my mom keeps
telling me you're going to burn your
finger you're going to burn your finger
you're going to burn your finger and all
the while i'm getting closer and closer
i had to find out for myself that i was
going to burn my finger and burn my
finger i did i feel like the texans are
only going to learn that they should
have just given in
and traded to sean watson
after this thing plays its out itself
out so far that they can't get then what
they could have gotten now
and that's what i've said all along is
going to happen mike this is just
headed somewhere with one side's gotta
give in and it does not sound like to me
from everything we've heard again we
have not heard directly from desean
watson as far as giving an interview
we've read the tweets we've heard things
elsewhere we have not heard directly
from him and maybe that's the next step
step is for him to talk
but the texans have dug their heels in
that that we have a franchise
quarterback and and frankly
he's only 15.94 million if he's on the
team 21.6 million in a dead cap head if
he's not on the team so i get from their
standpoint they've got the franchise
quarterback they don't have him at very
much money this year they want to build
around him with a new staff i get all
the reasons that houston wants to keep
him but if a guy doesn't want to play
for you i just don't know how that's
supposed to work because
i don't see him showing up for anything
not going to have the regular off season
so big deal
but when you get to training camp and
he's not there and you get to the first
week of the season and he's not there do
you suddenly realize this guy was
serious he's not going to show up wow
maybe we need to trade him at that point
it's too late mike
same thing they went through with dwayne
brown in 2017. he didn't show up trade
me trade betrayed me they ignored him
they ignored him they ignored him he
finally showed up and then they traded
him to the seattle seahawks and they
surely got less than if they had
maximized their leverage and looked at
the full market and gotten multiple
teams to the table back during the
uh training camp pre-training camp
off-season march may april time frame
all right uh i i'm just i'm convinced
i'm convinced that whatever they do
they're going to make the wrong move and
i'm fascinated by who's actually making
the decisions both in seattle and in
houston is it cal mcnair is it jack
eastwood is it nicerio how involved is
david culley who really has the weight
when it's time for the brain trust to
get together who's the one who's saying
we can't give in we can't give in even
if it may be in their best interest to
give in and we'll see if they ultimately
do give in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports